CATTALYYA NUENGSIGKAPIAN: Hello,
I'm Cattalyya Nuengsigkapian.
I am junior studying computer
science and engineering.
My project is camera system
for indoor localization
and human identification.
Smart home technology is
becoming more and more popular,
since it give people
the power to control
the device in their home,
to detect indoor accidents,
and to do health analysis.
To support this application
with multi-user,
many research try to
differentiate users
in their system.
But it is difficult for them
to achieve both high accuracy
and comfort at the same time.
These system either require user
to carry an extra device, which
trade-off the comfort, or use
the camera with very detailed
vision, recognition
[INAUDIBLE] face,
which can be very blurry in the
low resolution cameras or very
low speed camera in
most civilian system.
In order to achieve both
comfort and accuracy,
we continue to use camera system
and overcome the low resolution
issue by using the shirt
color as a temporary identity
of user.
My project start with using
OpenPose to track a human,
and then get their joints.
Then we use their joints--
the shoulder and elbow--
to extract the shirt.
As you can see in here,
that we draw the polygon.
Then we find all
possible identification
of people across
multiple camera.
Then we compute [? errors ?]
for each matched shirt
to be able to obtain
the best prediction.
At the end, we are
able to get around 93%
average accuracy with
this main improvement.
We also acknowledge that we use
shirt as a short-term identity.
This will allow us to
achieve real-time speed.
But in the future, we
will integrate this system
with other high accuracy,
but maybe slower,
and use heavyweight computation
like machine learning
to fill in the gap between
the short translation
when people no longer wear
the same shirt during the day.